en visual político en cuanto tenemos
oportunidad nos gusta hablar de asia y
de su cada vez mayor protagonismo lo
sabéis verdad en varios vídeos os hemos
hablado ya del impresionante desarrollo
que está teniendo este continente y
también de las increíbles oportunidades
que puede albergar
[Música]
sin embargo no todo es de color de rosas
en el nuevo corazón del mundo en asia
también podemos encontrar cómo decirlo
algunos claroscuros bueno decir esto es
quedarse tal vez muy cortos porque
amigos hacia la tierra de las
oportunidades como nos gusta decir aquí
en el canal tiene también caras menos
agradables y sin duda la peor de todas
es que esta tierra se está convirtiendo
en un gigantesco polvorín tal cual por
un lado esta zona del mundo cada vez
gasta más en armas de hecho se espera
que para 2020 la región suponga ya más
del 30 por ciento de todo el gasto
militar en el mundo
y encima se está convirtiendo creedme en
el gran tablero de ajedrez de la
geopolítica internacional fijaos china y
la india son grandes potencias
emergentes que cada vez más reclaman una
porción de influencia mayor la rusia de
putin ha empezado a poner su atención en
el pacífico eeuu también
vamos que hoy por hoy esta zona del
mundo está más cotizada que las entradas
al palco del bernabéu por otro lado las
discrepancias entre países están a la
orden del día en asia últimamente parece
que cualquier excusa es buena para
querer darse de bofetadas así que
podemos encontrar conflictos de todos
los colores y por todas las causas
económicas territoriales históricas que
es el conflicto de china con vietnam de
china con japón de china con la india el
caso de taiwán las disputas entre japón
y rusia- la situación en corea y bueno
así una larga lista de desencuentros
hablaremos mucho de ellos pero hoy nos
vamos a centrar en el que podemos
considerar un gigante dormido y por
cierto uno de mis países favoritos
japonés
[Música]
las dos pesadillas de japón
japón es la tercera economía del mundo a
pesar de lo cual este país ha tenido en
las últimas décadas un papel más que
discreto en la política internacional
sin embargo esto está empezando a
cambiar sobre todo por dos motivos china
y corea del norte
primero clarísimamente la emergencia de
china como nueva superpotencia y porque
esto le importa japón pues porque
políticamente no son dos países que se
lleven precisamente bien y desde luego
la emergencia de china supone de facto
un retroceso en la influencia regional
de japón por si fuese poco ambos países
mantienen un agrio conflicto por la
soberanía de un pequeño archipiélago
conocido como las islas senkaku las
islas senkaku están abandonadas pero
siguen siendo un punto clave para la
industria pesquera pues en yacimientos
de petróleo y gas y también son un
enclave estratégico para el comercio
marítimo
pues bien fijaos en el siguiente gráfico
para ver cómo ha evolucionado el
presupuesto militar de ambos países en
los últimos años y entenderéis la
preocupación que japón tiene por la
luego y demás actualidad está corea del
norte desde hace 20 años el régimen de
pyongyang está enfrascado en una carrera
por desarrollar capacidades de guerra no
convencional esto es fundamentalmente
sus capacidades de guerra nuclear
[Música]
hasta el momento ha conseguido fabricar
una bomba atómica de 30 kilos que viene
a ser algo así como dos veces la bomba
de hiroshima y también ha logrado
fabricar misiles balísticos que podrían
alcanzar no solo corea del sur sino
también japón en marzo de 2017 corea del
norte lanzó cuatro misiles balísticos
contra japón el ensayo tuvo relativo
éxito y tres de los cuatro misiles
cayeron en aguas territoriales de japón
a menos de 200 millas de la costa
pues bien todo esto podéis creerme está
generando auténtica psicosis en el país
nipón el propio gobierno japonés ha
comenzado a practicar evacuaciones ante
un hipotético ataque y también ha
distribuido una guía que detalla cómo
los ciudadanos japoneses deben responder
si un día corea del norte lanza un
ataque nuclear sobre el país según el
gobierno los ciudadanos tendrían unos 10
minutos para reaccionar desde que fuesen
avisados por un sistema de alertas
nacional preparado para notificar a la
población un ataque inminente por
mensajes de texto radio y televisión
sin embargo el tiempo disponible podría
ser incluso menor lo mismo puede tardar
en ser detectados dependiendo del caso
las advertencias y las alarmas podrían
sonar sólo 4 o 5 minutos antes de la
llegada del misil el caso es que además
de disparar la preocupación de todos los
japoneses normal la amenaza norcoreana
está disparando el negocio de refugios
antinucleares y también la compra de
dispositivos de purificación del aire
diseñados para combatir la radiación o
el gas venenoso siento haber el primer
ministro japonés ha confirmado que corea
del norte tiene también la capacidad de
lanzar contra japón misiles cargados con
gas sarín bien sea más o menos cierta la
amenaza norcoreana el caso es que estas
dos cuestiones china y corea del norte
son las grandes amenazas percibidas por
tokio pero antes de ver cómo el país
planea hacer frente a estas amenazas
veamos cuáles han sido las últimas
décadas las bases de su política de
defensa
[Música]
japón un país pacifista
como todos sabéis japón fue uno de los
países que perdieron la segunda guerra
mundial como consecuencia de esta
derrota en 1947 se le impuso al país una
constitución aún hoy vigente que
explícitamente renuncia a la guerra y al
uso de la fuerza excepto en caso de
defensa propia
aspirando sinceramente a una paz
internacional basada en la justicia y el
orden el pueblo japonés renuncia para
siempre a la guerra como derecho
soberano de la nación y a la amenaza o
al uso de la fuerza como medio de
solución de las disputas internacionales
no se mantendrán en los sucesivos
fuerzas de tierra mar o aire como
tampoco otro potencial bélico es decir
en un principio se llegó a contemplar
que japón no pudiera tener ejército la
protección del país correría a cargo de
eeuu sin embargo la guerra de korea y la
escalada de tensión en la guerra fría lo
cambió todo de repente tanto tokio como
washington entendieron que era
indispensable que se creasen una fuerza
de apoyo a las tropas estadounidenses en
caso de que hubiese que defender japón
así nacieron las fuerzas
autodefensa de japón una especie de
ejército cuyo único cometido posible es
la defensa eso si formalmente eeuu
continúa haciéndose cargo de la
protección de japón
de hecho la potencia americana tiene
desplegados en este país ojo más de 40
mil soldados y algunas de sus mayores
bases militares una fuerza que por
cierto es financiada por el propio
gobierno de japón y ojo el gobierno
japonés no sólo financia estas fuerzas
con entrega a eeuu más de 13 mil
millones de dólares para financiar la
guerra del golpe podemos decir como veis
que japón es la gran punta de lanza de
eeuu en asia sin embargo el nuevo
escenario que hemos visto respecto a
china y corea del norte ha hecho que
tokio ya no se conforme con esta
protección veamos ahora si como está
respondiendo japón a estas amenazas
[Música]
la nueva diplomacia de haber en primer
lugar el primer ministro de japón shinzo
abe ha iniciado una inusual carrera
diplomática para intentar contrarrestar
el creciente peso de china de momento ha
conseguido mejorar las relaciones con
corea del sur fortalecer los vínculos
con eeuu e incluso tender puentes con el
moscú de vladimir putin japón también
mantiene una intensa disputa con rusia
por la soberanía de un pequeño
archipiélago conocido como las islas
kuriles que a día de hoy están bajo
soberanía rusa
de hecho la diplomacia puesta en marcha
por ave es tan intensa que incluso la
competición con china ha llegado a
áfrica crece en la competencia entre
china y japón en áfrica y bueno como
curiosidad shinzo abe también fue el
primer líder internacional en reunirse
con trump en la famosa residencia que el
presidente de eeuu tiene en florida
en este encuentro parece que ave
consiguió caerle bien a donald parece
que consiguió un buen entendimiento con
trampa y eso que durante la campaña
electoral el presidente de eeuu se quejó
bastante de japón pero oye bueno las
cosas pueden cambiar estamos
comprometidos con la seguridad de japón
y con todas las áreas bajo su control
administrativo japón es nuestro aliado
al cien por cien pero claro la
diplomacia no es siempre suficiente
[Música]
el rearme de japón
y llegamos al punto clave a menudo se
interpreta que las fuerzas de
autodefensa de japón son una especie de
banda para nada su armada por ejemplo es
más grande que la de francia y reino
unido- juntas es verdad su nombre puede
hacer que no le demos importancia pero
las capacidades de este peculiar
ejército son espectaculares para muchos
analistas de hecho continúan siendo el
mejor ejército de asia a la espera eso
sí de que china finalmente le arrebate
ese puesto
[Música]
y es que ojo aunque japón invierte
relativamente poco en defensa menos del
1 por ciento de su pib
esto supone mucho muchísimo dinero en
2016 fue japón el séptimo país con mayor
gasto en defensa en 2017 destinará a sus
fuerzas armadas el mayor presupuesto de
su historia más de 5 trillones de yenes
unos 45 mil millones de dólares mucho
dinero en un ejército pequeñito y por
cierto muy bien entrenado da para
hacerse con los sistemas más modernos
por ejemplo el f-35 o también los
mejores drones de eeuu o 'los
portaaeronaves clase y zumo bueno para
los japoneses destructores defensivos o
incluso el nuevo caza de quinta
generación de fabricación local que está
desarrollando mitsubishi japón desvela
el prototipo de su primer caza furtivo
el caso es que desde que ave se
convirtió en primer ministro allá por
2012 ha tenido claro que había que dejar
atrás la vocación pacifista fijada a la
constitución japonesa y dicho y hecho en
2014 el gobierno japonés levantó la red
en esa la exportación de material bélico
con el objetivo de impulsar una
auténtica industria militar japonesa un
poco más tarde en 2015
abel lideró una reforma para que las
fuerzas de autodefensa pudieran operar
en el exterior y hoy incluso tienen una
base militar en yibutí
y por supuesto el presupuesto militar ha
vuelto a incrementarse tras muchos años
de recortes y ahí no queda todo ahora
incluso se habla de cambiar la
constitución el radical giro militar de
japón despierta fantasmas de la segunda
guerra mundial bueno tú qué opinas de ve
japón dejar a un lado su compromiso
pacifista debe en cambio hacer guiños y
cesiones a pekín el país se parece un
mejor aliado japón o china no dudes en
dejarnos tus respuestas en los
comentarios y darle a like si te ha
gustado el vídeo por cierto tenemos un
mensaje que trasladaron desde visual
política queremos daros las gracias a
todos los que desinteresadamente habéis
contribuido al canal con una aportación
en paypal nunca lo hemos pedido pero a
pesar de ello muchos habéis decidido
echarnos una mano haya sido mayor o
menor vuestra aportación muchísimas
gracias no sólo nos ayudáis a sacar
adelante este canal también nos facilita
es que podamos pensar en poner en marcha
nuevos proyectos así que lo dicho muchas
gracias un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]
[Aplausos]